goods and services tax better known as
okay other reason why are the reason why
I loves when you are born is because the
goods and services times came to affect
in Australia
surprise surprise in the year 2000 my
college yeah I remember it okay now the
GST is baked into all the commercial
goods and services that should buy um
you don't have to worry about
calculating so that for me bakes the
reasons why we care like well what
reason do we have to actually study if
it's all so soon done for and I've got
at least three reasons for you so I'm
going to give this to you in this order
these by the way they're not the reasons
but hopefully don't give you enough
metal hooks you'd be like why don't we
doing this again okay as I just
mentioned in Australia the GST is baked
into the price of whatever you bind
unlike in many other countries where
this is not the case of when you have a
look at the price tag you have to
mentally add on okay what's the sales
tax that's going to be included with
this purchase and you sort of have to
make sure that you do that as you go
otherwise you get to per checkout or the
tilt as they would call it and then you
don't have enough money and the most
notable example is the us part of the
reason why by the way is because in the
US they've got you know all these
different states and they have different
rules all of their sales taxes are all
different okay so in the US and you go
you're travelling anywhere where they
don't actually say it's not included
alright says reason that why might need
to travel a reason number two purchases
that you make
they include GST sometimes in unusual
way so I'll give you an example you guys
went on to actually not you guys went
every time you guys have gone on a camp
as part of school right you have to fork
over this large sum of money
able to go on ken yes now let me ask you
this do you think you pay GST on that
huh do you feel now feeling like the one
song interestingly this purchase that
you've made right camp
that's the purchase some of it you had
to jet pay GST on and some of it you
didn't pump it's a bit weird and a lot
of this has kind of worked out without
you having to worry about it but
eventually like the chances are either
indirectly or directly all of you are
gonna have your hands on some purchases
right if it's your business or your home
all those kinds of things you need to
understand for example for you guys you
did not have to pay GST for the camp
itself for like an accomodation and
forth whatever the people who actually
running your activities and what have
you but you didn't have to pay GST on
the food now the reason why is somewhat
long and secured us and economic
students explain a little more detail if
you like the simplest thing is you guys
don't have to pee GST for anything that
is what we call curriculum based so it's
like if you have to you're learning
something get a textbook do a business
competition do go on excursion all those
kinds of things you don't have to pay
GST for that the school pea on your path
but food is not a curriculum need right
that's like a physical oh okay now if
it's booty then its curriculum right so
then it suddenly changes so all that
just to say these purchases that get
made either on your behalf will buy you
they involved GST in sometimes
non-trivial went okay now the last thing
I want to add on as a reason is how many
you've been in important recently at all
okay now if you guys have been an
airport you know that airports have
special kinds of stores they don't know
they call it court DD free sample what
does um what does that mean
okay so a lot of taxes we just sort of
remember I said baked into the costs of
things that you buy they've been taken
off when you're at the airport okay now
and there are to a few other places
where you can do this
now just think for a moment we thought
about this last week about what taxes
are about like what's their purpose can
you tell me why are they called
duty-free and not tax-free even though
the tax rate is very good like tax is
not just like how the government just
wants to you know pull money off you
just for the sake of it right tax is an
embodiment of your financial duty to
your country it's like look you make
money you spend money you owe that to
the government so that they can do you
know for example put in place the
regulatory bodies that make sure that
all of these businesses you're buying
from aren't like flipping you off okay
simple example so therefore you have a
duty to do this but if you're a traveler
we don't even belong to this country you
have no duty to pay the tax of this
country
does that kind of make sense okay so
that's just a simple explanation of why
these kinds of things exist in GST is a
partner okay oh yes I'll charge you in
other ways okay now therefore we these
are our reasons there are four things
you need to four skills you need to have
to be able to understand and work with
GST okay so the first one is you've got
to know two different ways to find GST
and that's on the basis of whether you
might need to draw the student you are
considering the original price of um of
the items that you're buying effective
levels as original or if you're talking
about the tow price which includes the
GST that gets added onto the side here
and this diagram is actually going to
mean it's more just not just to look
pretty it's actually important for us as
we work out the numbers here because GST
in our country is what proportion of
your price
it's 10% very good so with your original
here can you do your best and divide it
up into try as well divide up into ten
equal portions okay so it's something
like this there we go okay yeah roughly
okay see what your original price and
the language here is really important
you've got the original price then
you've got the GST which is a tenth or
10% and then you've got what you would
call I suppose has like I think than I
thought
then you've got the total okay at the
total amount